this is the best interview I've ever had in
my life I love your line of questioning and um
getting to what what is real I hooked into Tim has
a childlike quality to him and I stay with that
innocence and that and don't take that innocence's
weakness or uh and uh when I read the scripture
I I feel truth good evil and I find the good
and let that just Pierce The Darkness [Music]
hello everyone watching and listening today
I have the pleasure of speaking to two people
someone you most likely know for his portrayal
of Jesus of Nazareth in Passion of the Christ
Jim Caviezel and also someone you should know
if you don't already The Man Behind operation
Underground Railroad Tim Ballard we discussed the
new film The Sound of freedom wherein Mr cavizo
plays Tim Bellard in the telling of his real life
story detailing his fight against the increasingly
worldwide and pervasive childhood sex trade the
film The Sound of Freedom releases on July 4th
so about a week and a half ago I got a text
message from Tony Robbins uh suggesting that
I watch a new film called the sound of freedom and
I did that about four days ago with my wife Tammy
and was quite struck by the movie and I decided
to follow up on it it details out the efforts of
one man Tim Bellard to investigate uh the a child
sexual slave ring and to rescue the children that
were associated with that but it also points to
a broader social problem which is the spread of
sexual and slave trafficking worldwide abetted by
the gnat which is a great Avenue for Psychopathic
criminals to pursue their darkest desires with
very little risk of being caught especially on
the multinational basis so I've decided to I to to
reach out to Tim Bellard who is the um the man who
who the movie is about and to Jim Caviezel who's
the actor that plays him to talk about what all
this signifies and so Tim let's start with you
I mean the movie makes the case that there is
a widely expanding network of slavery essentially
making itself manifest worldwide concentrating in
no small part on very young children who
are being sold repeatedly to pedophilic
Psychopaths to have at their will and of course
can be sold repeatedly for that purpose and the
movie makes the case that this is now an
operation that's rivaling the drug trade
in magnitude so you know it sounds like yet
another right-wing conspiracy so please why
don't you walk us through what you know and and
and help me understand and everybody watching and
listening exactly what you think is going on yeah
thank you so much uh Jordan we're so grateful uh
you take your time to do this with us so I spent
12 years as a special agent undercover operator
with the Department of Homeland Security most of
my time 90 of that time was spent investigating
these cases child crimes child trafficking and in
fact those numbers are correct uh that are being
this these are Department of Labor U.N these
are sources that um you know the the best we
have that say that there's close to Six Million
children or more who are forced into sex slavery
labor slavery or organ harvesting and I can
attest that I have been involved in in cases
involving all three of those forms of slavery
multiple times and is absolutely is a real thing
um it's not even far far from home uh it's the
United States is the number one consumer year
after year of child rate material and oftentimes
we we're close to number one in production
um and it's a serious matter you know the case um
the story and the sound of Freedom kicks off with
the rescue of a little boy at the Port of Entry uh
the southern border that's a real story a real boy
um that I I was on that Port of Entry I was 10
years on the southern border so when you have 85
000 unaccompanied minors showing up in the last
two years being let into the country without the
sponsor being vetted DNA checked background
checked um you know I called the economy of
pedophilia at the United States where the demand
85 000 children thousands of them are under five
years old are are LED into the country so we
have we have a serious serious problem and
uh it's it's not being addressed as it should
be hopefully this film can do that have have
what has been your experience with regard to
so-called mainstream Media or Legacy media
coverage how much attention has been paid to this
and if not much why and if reasonably who and how
well I think not not very much has been
uh you know attention has been given by
mainstream media oftentimes it's more innocent
than cynical perhaps where it's just this is too
dark I don't want to expose our audience to
this horrific thing um you know we I I film
we film our operations I mean I I'm going
to post today another operation in in West
Africa of a baby Factory I mean these are real
cases where they've they've kidnapped women
um as young as 13 year olds and children and
they impregnate them they rape them and they
make babies and they take these babies and sell
them for their organs sell them for sex sell them
for a Satanic ritual abuse like it's it's it does
sound crazy that's why I film it our operations
we film our operations so that we can show the
world this is very real it's really happening
um and I think if there's two million children
forced into commercial sex which is this the
most uh kind of credible statistic that we can
find a lot of people are involved so there is a
more cynical answer to your question which may
be there's people that don't want this exposed
the because they're involved in it so I'm going to
harass you a bit here um from the Wikipedia page
um there is some not that I'm particular
particular fan of Wikipedia Pages uh depending on
the circumstances but there are some criticisms of
what you're doing and I thought we might as well
um address them right off the bat bat
because people who are watching are
going to be look man if I was coming across
this for the first time and in some ways I am
I've got two choices in front of me don't I I can
either presume that you've discovered something
that's ongoing and of tremendous significance
that's terribly dark or I can assume that the
difficult work that you had done for a decade um
genuinely addressing these problems has made you
hypersensitive to a threat and willing to magnify
it and it would be easier just to ignore you as a
consequence now that would be the preferable
um outcome to such an investigation wouldn't
it so you can as as you said you can understand
why people might want to avert their eyes from
such a thing so I'm going to walk through these
criticisms and maybe you could you know you can
respond to them and we can get that out of the
way before we go deeper into the film and and
your your uh in your your uh your operations so
so your group and this is Operation Underground
Railroad and tell me if I get anything wrong here
says it devours conspiracy theories though founder
Tom Bellard was criticized for refusing
to condemn the Q Anon conspiracy theory
um I have no idea what the hell that
means do you know what that's referring to
yeah absolutely we um that's that's a lie in
Wikipedia we have absolutely an rfaqs for years
have have condemned the majority of of what we
see um with conspiracy theories uh so I they like
to attribute me to the Q Anon movement um there
may be some truths in there but there's so many
falsehoods on top of that so our FAQs refute that
immediately um because it can it discredits the
movement in fact I would go so far as to consider
that maybe certain people who don't want this
known are responsible for some of the conspiracy
theories in order to discredit the movement
um and uh they go too far they go too far in in
their assessment of things but yeah we absolutely
have just disavowed uh what's generally coming out
of of Q Anon yeah well it says you know it's very
vague on Wikipedia it says to condemn the Q Anon
conspiracy theory well I know perfectly well that
there are more than one conspiracy theories let's
say on Q and on so I'm not even exactly sure what
it's referring to what is there a particular
conspiracy theory that um you were criticized
for refusing to condemn do you have any more
specific details about that I mean I I'm not
sure what exactly they're talking about Pro they
might be uh referring to the fact that there's
something called adrenal Chrome where they take
they're taking children's blood and devouring it
and so forth uh and I've explained my experience
with that and and I just did in West Africa and
other places we've seen this in in several parts
of the continent of Africa and it's very real it's
very real This Witch doctory they take these
children we they they take their organs they
take their blood they they they drink it they take
the genitalia of children and and hang it over the
rooftop of their businesses thinking that the the
dark Gods will bless them these are real things
um and so I might say something like that and
then they connect it to something uh that a q
Anon person says about you know a celebrity who
must be doing this too but there's no evidence
to back that and they make they make a false
connection there um and and so that's that's
the only example I can think of okay got it well
the next thing it says is that the the operation
underground Railway fall mostly claimed that it
had entered a partnership with American Airlines
that was in 2022 so what do you what do you what
do you have to say about that oh there's a great
one so a PR firm uh who represented um us made a
deal with American Airlines uh came to us and said
shoot the video they're going to put this video
on your uh we're gonna put there for this video on
the airlines they shot the video of me I just get
a call from our PR Company to put me in a studio
I give a video that I think I'm talking to the
passengers for one month uh on American Airlines
apparently the deal fell through the PR Company
didn't tell us that and our our marketing company
our marketing team put out hey we're going to be
on American Airlines the PR Company apologized
we had we fired them they said we can't believe
we didn't get the message to you and that was it
and of course there's people that want so badly
for us to be wrong or us to not do what we say we
do so they exploited that I think that was a vice
magazine very incredibly dishonest uh Journal uh I
can't call him journalist us the vice magazine did
they've done a series of hit pieces on this and I
I encourage people I encourage people to read it
readvice readvice because everything they say is
so ridiculous and so dishonest right right yes
well and I I do believe if I remember correctly
the advice is also declared bankruptcy in the last
few weeks and I can't imagine an organization more
richly deserving there was a 2021 follow-up
article from Vice but I don't think we're
going to I'll just read part of it because it's so
ridiculous conflating consensual sex work with sex
trafficking yeah well that's exactly the kind of
Weasley um what would you call it criticism that
I'd expect from people who were trying to justify
the sorts of behaviors that you are attempting to
expose um then there's a 2021 article in slate
criticizing a 2014 raid conducted by operation
underground Railway in the Dominican Republic
saying that it was likely to have traumatized
the traffic children um Ann Gallagher an
authority on human trafficking wrote in 2015
that our had an alarming lack of understanding
about how sophisticated criminal trafficking
networks must be approached and dismantled and
called the work of our arrogant unethical and
illegal so and have a way of that oh thank you
I'm grateful for this opportunity so someone
like Ann Gallagher who lives 3000 miles away from
any operation we've ever done is not qualified to
talk about what our operations she can't give
any uh details she can't give any examples
um the Slate article is a fun one to address I've
addressed it several times um we um early on we
brought a blogger down to do to to watch our
operations we we invite people down but if Tony
Robbins has been down um we invite politicians the
Attorney General of Utah's coming our operations
um if we're hiding something that's the last thing
we would of course do so we bring this journalist
this blogger I won't call her a journalist
um and we thought she was a friend and she
came and watched a legit legitimate operation
happened in in Dominican Republic there were
seven traffickers who showed up seven traffickers
arrested there were um 20 plus uh people rescued
nine of them were children you can't you can't
sometimes you can't always uh control who shows
up to the sting party the traffickers bring
who they will but nine children uh showed up
they were all liberated from the the the the
the um you know the control of their captors
um this blogger then wrote two glowing stories
about it that she witnessed this she had very
minimal exposure to the operation itself
she she witnessed it some seven years later
she decides to use it in my opinion to
somehow increase her social media following
as our foundation grew and she writes a story
it's in slate now here's here's the key thing
um nine children rescued and nine children
had three years of Aftercare services in
this operation provided by International Justice
mission one of the top authorities in Aftercare
and and fighting human trafficking um seven
traffickers were not only arrested but all seven
were convicted so she chose the wrong case to
criticize now tellingly if if anyone's gonna write
a story about that operation good bad or otherwise
and they leave out the part that says seven
traffickers were arrested and seven traffickers
were convicted and nine children were liberated
and had three years of Aftercare to heal them if
you leave that part out either you are extremely
incompetent as a researcher and writer or you're
a liar either way the story has zero credibility
on that fact alone that you because she doesn't
even report on those two on those two essential
elements all right well we've hypothetically
dispensed with Vice which of course is a
yeah well it's pretty funny that that's what they
named their organization as far as I'm concerned
and we'll leave the Slate issue aside Jim let me
ask you a couple of questions if you don't mind
do you want to first of all tell people um about
your involvement with Angel Studios a little bit
about your career and why this particular movie
sound of Freedom it's it it's opening what in
early July is it July when does it come out it
comes out uh July 4th week so next week next week
it's it's it's out in theaters uh Nationwide so
so let me turn to Jim Jim can you hear me yes yes
all right so yeah do you want to detail out your
your association with Angel Studios tell everybody
first who Angel studios are what they've done
and I've watched a lot of the chosen by the way
which I thought was extremely high quality um do
you tell us about the studio tell us about your
involvement with them about your career and then
about your attraction to this particular movie
well let's start with the movie first um I
have three uh adopted children from China
I became aware of the dangers that go on um with
children around the world and through that process
um then I became aware of Tim Ballard and
coincidentally then my friend Eduardo verastigi
brought me this script because many of the
actors that they had offered it to didn't
want to get involved in this particular project
I read the script I love the movie Taken and I
thought this is like taken but with a much bigger
heart then Tim Ballard came to the meeting he had
seen two films that I did one was called The
Count of Monte Cristo and then the other one
was The Passion of the Christ and he felt that
I'd be the right guy to play him Angel Studios
I had nothing no connection to them until a few
months ago when they wanted to do this movie
and they wanted their idea was to sell 2 million
tickets for these two million trafficked children
so why why is it that a number of actors why in
your estimation did a number of actors turn down
the opportunity to play the role what and and and
why and why did you decide to forego that risk and
to and to climb aboard I foregoed the risk because
when you have uh three children that you loved
when you'd give your life for it kind of connects
into Tim Ballard and Tim did this for this little
girl and the children that he saves it's something
uh is a greater purpose that even your career
uh you know like I I went through this with Mel
Gibson when we did the passion that my career
was the last thing I thought of what I thought
about was the God I love and I put this in how
I look at it is is that this God that I love it
he loves me and he deserved to be loved back and
so I I would be nothing without him he gave me my
purpose and this life so um the the Tim Ballard I
was very fortunate that he had seen those um films
and um when I looked at and I think Tim made this
comparison Schindler's List was a very uh powerful
weapon but it came 50 years too late this film is
now this is exposing it now during that time and
I believe that is probably why it's easier to get
an OCTA to do a movie 50 years later there's no
controversy it's over but the the individuals
imagine if Rwanda if that story had been made
that movie had been made during that time or
that they could see it you know it you you have
to look at these situations and understand that
um good people sit back and do nothing and allow
this evil to occur there's got to be people that
stand up in the time that it occurs and that's
what drew me to the whole story in the first place
and do you do you how how do you feel about
the movie now you've seen the movie in its
entirety it's about to be released uh it's a
fully fledged high quality production I was
particularly impressed by the cinematography um it
it's also extraordinarily well edited the acting
um I don't want to flatter you but the acting is
extremely high quality it's very realistic movie
um how how do you how how do you feel about your
involvement now that everything is done and and
how do you feel about the what would you say
the production capacity of Angel Studios which
is a relatively you know it's a relatively new a
relative newcomer on the on the mass entertainment
block when I was sitting next in Tim Ballard and
he leaned over and he started to weep uh heavily I
knew I did my job so do you want to run us briefly
through I don't want to give away the entire plot
because that would obviously be pointless but do
you want to just run this briefly through Jim the
the the the plot of the movie and then I'll turn
to Tim and fill in some of the background details
of his life and so I play Tim Ballard he's a
Homeland Security he sets up these um uh sting
operations to take down these very very bad men uh
to save traffic children and one particular case
one of the traffickers that he takes down earned
slipachinski uh who's he he rescues this boy and
the little boy turns to him and says will you save
my sister and Tim goes back gets the direction
from above and from his wife and goes back and
he sells everything to find this little girl
so what I liked about the script so I've
noticed that one of the most effective ways
of communicating complex ideas effectively is to
particularize the problem and so what happens in
this movie is that the broad problem of sexual of
of slavery and human trafficking and the somewhat
narrower problem of sexual trafficking of
children is zeroed uh is is what focused
on a particular case and so that gives the movie a
very powerful narrative underpinning right because
when our problem is particularized and you can see
how it affects actual specific people's lives it
becomes much more realistic and much more palpable
and I thought the movie did a good job of that
uh Tim do you want to walk everybody listening
through let's go back into the details of your
life now you worked for this you you worked we
worked for the Special Forces per se and who who
are you working for before you decided to forego
your career and to pursue this the case that we're
describing so I worked for 12 years as a special
agent and undercover undercover operator for the
Department of Homeland Security the investigative
division called Homeland Security investigations
10 of those years were spent on the border uh
tracking child traffickers people who would
exploit children with child exploitation material
so I really learned a lot in 2006 the laws changed
in the United States and for the first time
U.S agents were permitted and encouraged to go
overseas and find children who Americans were
abusing and we could now hold those Americans
accountable as if they had committed that crime
on U.S soil that's that's what really changed my
life because I started I speak Spanish fluently
and they sent me overseas South of the Border
that's when my eyes opened up and I started seeing
the children that I used to only see mostly on the
on the pornography on the child expectation
material cases um but it was tormenting me uh
the US government unwittingly was because if I
couldn't find that connection back to the United
States States the American kid or the American
pedophile I had to come home but the problem
is I've already been exposed to the children
I've already been exposed to the problem and
oftentimes have made myself debate and in 2012
I had enough on this case I kind of went more I
went further than otherwise I probably should have
the movie didn't have time to tell you that there
was another case in Haiti at the same time that I
was working uh thinking there was a U.S Nexus and
I was told in both instances to come home and you
couldn't work these cases and that's when I had a
very consequential conversation with my wife and
I said if I stay here if I do this operation with
or without my badge it doesn't matter at this
point I I'm I can do the work we will save kids
um and um but I I have to lose my job and we have
six children and this is this is a moral dilemma
like I've never faced in my life and I was hoping
my wife would have responded with get your ass
home you can't you can't abandon us you know first
of all you're gonna die without the top cover of
the US government if you continue this and who's
going to pay the bills and feed the feed the kids
she didn't say that she said to me you have to
quit your job it was that easy for her um it
became spiritual for her even she felt a calling
and a responsibility that she might have to reckon
with one day when she meets her maker and I knew
that she felt that way when she told me this in
the crucial moment of decision about two days
before I ended up turning my badge and gun over
and and went private she said to me I will not let
you jeopardize my salvation by not doing this and
when she said those words and I knew she meant
those words that changed everything for me and
we jumped into really just an irrational Act of
service I might call it because it wasn't rational
in many in many ways but ultimately it ended in
the operation UC depicted in the film which shows
54 children uh some uh some adult young young
adult women were in that group as well rescued
on that island but what the movie doesn't uh have
the time to report is that in actuality was 120
um there was two other locations being taken down
at the same time and there's a documentary that's
going to follow uh in in the wake of sound of
Freedom called triple take Angel Studios will
put it out uh documenting the entire story and so
in the end it was successful and we were able to
build upon that success and I founded operation
Underground Railroad I run another Foundation
that was founded by Glenn Beck called the Nazarene
fund and we're doing these kind of operations all
over the world today so how let's go back in
time to before you worked as a security agent
for the homelands homeless or an agent for the
homeland security investigations unit how did
you how were you trained to do that like what was
your background before you became employed as an
agent and what was it about you that made you
capable of engaging in this sort of operation
so I I I got a graduate degree in um International
politics and I always wanted to be in federal law
enforcement my first job was CIA I was there
doing 911 um working in the operations center
in the wake of 9 11. I found out that I studied
terrorism and weapons of mass destruction uh that
was the the actually the degree I got at the
Monterey Institute of international studies
um and so um it was an easy recruit into the
CIA because you know 911 had just happened when
I found out that one of the terrorists Muhammad
attah had staged his attack from Mexicali Mexico
across the border and I speak Spanish I wanted
to go fight terrorism on the southern border so
I ended up jumping on the ship from CIA and
I joined the newly created Homeland Security
Department and it became a special agent for six
months I was tracking those kind of movements
uh you know not not human trafficking or child
exploitation but money guns terrorism six months
into that Endeavor I was called into the office
of a supervisor and they asked me if I would
please forgo everything that I wanted to do with
my career and help them start a child crimes unit
I do not know why they asked me uh one thing he
did say to me was you're a young agent but you're
a person of faith and we know that about you and
that's that's a requirement or you're you're your
soul will be crushed the Bible is a root of
wisdom inspiration and spiritual nourishment
the Halo app empowers you to explore the Bible's
profound teachings and to effortlessly incorporate
them into your daily life a great place to start
while you deepen your understanding of the Bible
is to check out father Mike schmitz's Bible in a
year available on the hollow app exclusively for
brief daily readings and Reflections here you can
dive into an extensive library of Bible reading
plans accompanied by insightful Reflections
and audio guided meditations whether you're
a seasoned Bible reader or just starting your
journey hallow provides a platform for you to
engage with scripture like never before studying
the Bible's literary Brilliance has influenced
countless writers poets and artists throughout
history by studying the Bible yourself you'll
gain a deeper appreciation for the power of
Storytelling symbolism and metaphor enriching
your understanding of literature across different
genres the Hallow app also helps you connect with
a community of like-minded individuals sharing
experiences insights and encouragement along the
path to spiritual growth download the app
for free at hallow.com Jordan you can set
reminders and track your progress along the way
enrich your education and nurture your mind and
soul today download the Hallow app at hallow.com
Jordan that's hallow.com Jordan for an exclusive
free month free trial of all six thousand plus
prayers and meditations I would like you if you
would to tell us to the degree that you can
what you were typically dealing with when you
started when you started working for the child
sex crimes unit let us know what you saw let us
know what you what that did to you because that
sort of thing that changes people's conceptions
of humanity per se let's say the nature of the
cosmos and what it means to be human right I mean
when you're when you're in contact with people
who are capable of that level of Darkness you
start to understand something about the nature
of the human soul that you can't understand any
other way and that can be a I mean that's the
sort of thing that gives people post traumatic
stress disorder when they're soldiers so and and
now you said also your supervisors had an inkling
that you might be protected against that at least
to some degree because of your faith so let's walk
through what you learned and encountered first
what what did you see when you were working as
part of this child sex crimes unit what I saw was
so shocking Jordan uh I thought child sex crimes
would be 15 year olds 16 year olds uh my brain
couldn't comprehend something more evil than
abusing that age the very first case I worked in
2002 I believe I was given a bunch of VHS videos
some hard drives to look at that had been seized
in a warrant the very first image I saw um were um
there were three uh three little boys ah
that were probably seven five and three
and they looked uh like they looked like my
children they had you know they had blonde
blonde eye blonde hair blue eyes and they
were being just raped raped these three
little boys by this pedophile and I was
so shocked I fell to my knees I dry heaved
thinking I was going to throw up into the
waste basket I jumped into my car I drove
to my children's School my three oldest kids I
checked them out I still remember in my mind I
can still see dentist dentist appointment I wrote
and I grabbed them I took them home and just
sobbed on the floor my wife came in and I just I
wouldn't let the kids go just holding them shaking
um that was my very first experience uh you talked
about PTSD I absolutely deal with PTSD to this day
um I I took too long to actually deal with it
uh that's another story um and I thought I can't
I can't do this I can't do this um I started
getting help immediately uh because I didn't
want to quit and uh that that's that's what this
is that's what this is and those kind of videos
have increased over the last couple years by
five thousand percent yeah well in in Canada
um we just had a report from an organization
called the Western Standard that one million child
sexual exploitation photos and videos have been
identified in an Alberta child porn investigation
one million photos eight arrests made okay so
that's some indication of the widespread nature
of the problem now you said that when you first
encountered this material it made you physically
ill and also terrified for the safety of your
children but then also it necessitated you seeking
um health I suppose or Aid I mean I've worked
with people who've had post-traumatic stress
disorder generally what happens is that tragedy is
not enough to give someone post-traumatic stress
disorder even if it's rather severe it has to be
a combination of tragedy and malevolence and the
real trauma comes as a consequence of contact
with evil with malevolence and what people
generally have to do in order to recover
from that is to develop a rather profound
philosophy of evil and you know a religious
faith in in its most fundamental Essence is a
philosophy of Good and Evil it it does detail
out the Heart of Darkness among human beings
point out to people this is particularly although
you not not uniquely true of the Christian
tradition but particularly true that that capacity
for evil lurks in the heart of everyone and that
are fundamental moral obligation as we Soldier
and here on Earth is to overcome that proclivity
within and also to stand up against it in the
external world and so you said you received
some Aid after you had been exposed to this first
set of videos um what what is it about the way you
looked at the world that had to change in order
for you to adapt to what you were encountering
well I had to come to grips with the the an idea
that I had never been confronted with before that
there are people and not a few but millions
of people only millions of of pedophiles could
justify a demand of millions of child exploitation
uh material videos and so forth uh the first
person you see arrested in the movie is a real
person named ursulchinski in sound of Freedom he
had over 2 million pieces of child rape material
in his house so um to to be confronted with the
reality that there are people on this planet and
like like I said not a few but but Millions who
want to indulge in watching five-year-old children
be raped and sexually assaulted in ways that and
I'm sorry to be so raw but I feel comfortable
with you Dr Peterson but uh to to to watch
children's bodies actually break in the act
of sexual assault acts that your mind couldn't
conjure up if you tried to conjure it up and
that it's real that is so shocking to the system
um it changes your life forever I I tell
people if I feel like I've had a million
holes burned into my brain because I've watched
thousands of hours of that kind of material not
only not only watch it and I love the scene
that Jim depicts where he's it's that's very
real I I break I can't watch I can't watch
the movie but the movie's very good the
movie doesn't show any of this by the way it
doesn't show anything like this I don't want
people to run away and be scared but you
see the scene where the the camera flashes
um a close-up into Jim's eyes and that's that was
me for for 10 years not only watching but writing
writing it in details for the court to see for
the prosecutors to see and and raising children
at the same time that are the very same age and
fortunately or unfortunately for me I have now I
have nine children that at the time I I left the
government at six and so I can always identify
the age of a child with one of my own children
and my mind was almost automatically doing is
I would superimpose my own children's faces and
persons onto these children and that's that led to
um that led to the PTSD I'll be honest um and
almost a paranoia about what would happen to my
children and watching my children and I've come a
long ways and and I'm I'm able to deal with it but
I I I I was determined never to quit and so I just
sought more help and I I won't quit so okay so Tim
I'm I'm gonna walk you through what I know about
how people turn into the sort of pedophile that
you find so you and everyone else I suppose
or virtually everyone else finds so mysterious
so I'm going to refer first to the story of Cain
and Abel because it actually puts its finger on
the process in a stunning manner so what happens
in that story is that two different Pathways to
adaptation are detailed out and they become the
Cardinal Pathways of adaptation that characterize
the whole human race immersed as it is from that
point onward in history instead of in the Garden
of Eden and one is the pathway of Cain and the
other is the pathway of Abel now Abel makes high
quality sacrifices he's all in right he puts
himself on the line and he does the real thing
and as a consequence God finds God uh finds
he finds favor with God and His sacrifices
are rewarded he does well and everyone loves
him and he thrives and Cain his sacrifices are
not of the same quality he tries to cut the
corners and to and to pull the wool over his
eyes and and God's eyes and everyone else's eyes
and as a consequence his sacrifices are rejected
and instead of clueing the hell in and waking
up and taking responsibility for his failure
he decides that he's going to call out God for
creating a cosmos that's cosmically unfair and
unjust and the evidence for that is Kane's
failure and Abel's success and so he has a
little chat with God and he basically calls
him out and says you know I'm breaking myself
in half here and nothing's going my way and
Abel gets everything he wants and you know
how dare you make a cosmos so radically unjust
and improper and why don't you just straighten
yourself out and God says if you did well
you would be rewarded for it and you should
look to yourself and then he says something
even worse and this is very subtle because
um it's complicated to understand it unless you
look at multiple translations or potentially the
original Hebrew which I can't read but I read
the multiple translations God says to Cain
the spirit of sin crouches at your doorstep
like a sexually aroused predatory animal
and you have invited it in to have its way with
you and so now if you study the development of the
fantasies of very very dark people you see that
they brewed and fantasize in isolation for years
and the fantasies get darker and darker and darker
so they're bitter and resentful to begin with
and then they start fantasizing about well
what they would want that can take a sexual
end or it can take a very violent and or it can
take both and what they're really after is the
ultimate in Revenge and on the sexual front they
find a kick in extending the what would you call
it unacceptability of the fantasy one stage at a
time um the the famous and extremely attractive
sexual serial killer what was his name he's
a famous photograph of him like this very
attractive man do you remember his dad Bundy
Ted Bundy Ted Bundy detailed out exactly how
his fantasies progressed as he became more and
more involved with pornography and what happens
in some sense is that these people who are nursing
these terrible fantasies want to stay on the edge
of novelty and so their fantasies get darker and
darker and darker as they progress down that road
and so after a thousand such micro progressions
they end up in exactly the sort of pit that
you're describing and some of that is pure sexual
kick because of the novelty and but it's got this
sadistic and perverse uh vengeful twist and you
could think about it this way you know I think
it says in the gospels that you know it would be
better that that a most Millstone was hung around
your neck and that you were cast into the abyss
than to do harm to any of God God's children let's
say and the that's actually where the perverse
Delight comes because the most egregious possible
sin let's say is the violent sexual abuse of the
most innocent possible person and the perverse
novelty kick is highest at exactly that point and
then that just goes from bad to worse and there's
a thousand or even ten thousand micro decisions
that go along with that there's also a great book
called Ordinary men this is well worth reading
although it's a bloody catastrophe to read I'll
tell you it details out how a group of German
policemen who were moved to Poland during World
War II were transformed from ordinary middle class
working class or sorry ordinary working class men
um old enough to not have been raised under the
Nazi regime by the way and so not propagandized
into a kind of mindless obedience how they went
from being perfectly ordinary policemen to the
sort of people who could take naked pregnant women
out into the middle of the field and shoot them in
the back of the head and it isn't like they had
an easy time with that some of them reported the
same sort of thing that you reported when you
first watched that video they would they what
they were being called upon to do stage by stage
made them physically ill and they had a commander
who actually had told them that they could leave
the service if they didn't want to continue with
their duties but they felt Duty bound not to lead
leave their comrades having to mop up the terrible
situation but it does a lovely job of detailing
out how your movement from normality to Absolute
perversity is a consequence of ten thousand micro
um what would you say micro violations of your own
conscience not all of the micro obviously so you
know you need to know about the vengefulness you
need to know about the kick of sadism that's that
novelty kick that produces a dopaminergic kick
that heightens sexual satisfaction and so there's
an there's an element of sadistic misery that can
add novelty to sex that's particularly attractive
to people who are bitter and resentful because
they actually can't find any willing sexual
partners and so they're angry at the world
and shake their fist to God because of it and so
anyways that's a bit of the developmental course
of such of such a lovely descent into hell and and
the interesting thing about it is that people Brew
Day like you don't get to the point where you're
watching pornographic videos of children being
raped without hundreds or even thousands of hours
of increasingly demented voluntary fantasy and
that's that allowing the spirit of sin that would
otherwise crouch on your doorstep to enter your
house and have its way with you right it's like
a collaborative Venture with Satan himself that's
the most straightforward way of describing it and
so well so that's I don't know what you have to
say about that but I'll let you have at her I'll
say this that everything you're saying absolutely
he resonates with my anecdotal experiences dealing
with these people I look into their eyes and what
you're describing is what I see though I've never
been able to articulate it like you just have
so I appreciate being armed with with um with an
understanding that it will help me uh evangelize
more clearly to others about the dangers of
of over stimulation and overview support of
pornography and and shaking hands with the devil
so thank you for that that was very insightful
so I I spent a bit of time um not a lot but
a bit of time inside a maxim security prison
when I was a kid I worked with a very strange
psychologist that was there and one of the
things that really shocked me and I I think this
shocked me enough to change my whole life was
I I met these I met this one prisoner who was a
pretty non-descript looking character he took me
for a walk out in the yard away from a gym full
of like weight lifting Ax Murderer monsters and
rapists and we went for a walk out in the yard
and the psychologist called us back and told me
later in the office that this guy who's about
five two pretty non-pre-possessing guy had uh
made two policemen Neil in front of him begged
for their lives in reference to their families
and then shot them both in the back of the head
and and kicked them aside and the shocking thing
to me was you know you kind of think that if you
met pure evil it would it would have a monstrous
form and you know the thing that shocked me about
that was the non-descript nature of this guy you
know his his absolutely banal ordinariness
the fact that you could just walk past him
on the street you'd never know he wasn't some
monster you know the Monstrous character of
Satan in your imagination is you know a figure
that's terrifying to behold instead of someone
normal you know what I mean normally in that
cringing sense these people that you've interacted
with like what's your what's your reaction to them
when you talk to them the pedophiles when you talk
to them and when you arrest them my experience
is very similar to what you just described very
nondescript people of all walks of life we've
we've we've arrested and I've interrogated
um Educators uh lawyers law enforcement clergyman
um and and uh sitting across from them there's but
with no apparent physicality that would tell you
who they are but I will say this when they start
talking and I look into their eyes that's when
I can I sense something that that really scares
the hell out of me um and the way they talk
about children when they get there and it's
it's something that they've been able to normalize
and they're speaking to me about children almost
like they're talking about you know the weather or
you know talking about buying and selling children
like you talk about buying and selling computer
parts or an automobile or something and that's
where I thought you something has taken over
you something non-human has made you less human
um and I've never been able to figure it
out uh only that it creeps me out and and
um and I usually end up getting them to confess
because they have brought themselves to a place
where they think they're okay they think that
it's somehow normal I don't know if that makes
sense how do they do Dr Peterson well well the
the degree of rationalization that has to with
each with each step forward in the progress of
the fantasy there has to be a step forward in the
self-deception with regards to self-description
right so imagine that you're you're attempting to
cling to a sense of yourself at least as normal
but even maybe as a moral agent I mean the the
more forthright pedophiles claim that they're
only allowing children to express their true
sexual desires and that what they're actually
doing is forming the best relationship with the
children that they've ever had now of course
there's part of them that knows that that's
an absolutely bloody screaming hellish lie but
you get to that lie like I said with a thousand
micro lies right and you're modifying your
self-conception along the way I mean have you
had these people justify themselves to you and
if so by what means do they attempt to do that
so one person that comes to mind absolutely the
answer is yes and one person that comes to mind is
the person depicted in the film oshensky uh this
person had written uh articles self-published of
course he had a book that he actually sold
on Amazon and his understanding or his his
justification was that the puritanical Society
of this country has crushed the true uh and and
and beautiful and righteous uh sexual experience
uh which the most natural would be between a man
and a child a prepubescent child a prepubescent
child is is is the is the most beautiful form of
humanity and um and why why take that away from a
child's children would be well uh conditioned to
to to confront the challenges of life if only they
could experience orgasmic pleasure even in their
prepubescence um this is how they talk right right
and right yeah well that you saw because of that
there was attempts made in the 1970s by French
intellectuals surprise surprise to have the age of
consent reduce radically and that was always the
rationale it was an extension of the patriarchal
oppression theory in some sense right that all
sexual expression is essentially pure and good
in its most fundamental form and it's all warped
by social pressure and if we were just allowed to
express ourselves in every manner that we saw fit
that everyone would be free and we wouldn't suffer
any more from the constraints of of tyrannical
Society right and it's just convenient for the
bloody pedophiles that that happens to justify
them doing whatever they the hell they want to
children who are obviously too young to consent
right so he is a good example I forgot about that
in the book Jim let me ask you so now you didn't
have to go through the same things that Tim did
and you obviously weren't subject to the same
kind of exposure but you had to play this role
and you had to act out in your imagination
the darkness that characterized the people
who played your enemies let's say on the screen
what were the consequences for you of having to
delve even on the fictional landscape into this
entire uh what would you say underworld domain
well let's um start with your story
initially when you brought up Cain and Abel
um in my years of working with agents like
Tim and I actually worked with other agents
because Tim was very busy doing Missions at the
time and I got to go in to a lot of his world I
mean those are the guys that I play so I don't
imitate other actors I go and meet these guys
and really learn and study what they do Cain
and Abel for example able is doing good things
for God how would Cain hurt God by killing Abel
by wounding him when I go and play for example
a serial killer or a man that you mentioned
earlier Ted Bundy who my friend uh broke that
case and found out who he was Mike tando so
you're the Beast that comes in you he he he
um comes in and he um deceives you and and
starts with the ego and the whole thing
and then eventually the turn is is how that you're
eventually not fair on non-servient uh becomes
um one who how can I wound God the most by killing
the most innocent child and it wounds God in the
greatest way when you take these innocent children
who've done nothing and have no sin and these guys
um uh um have the attitude which you were
mentioning earlier all the cutting of the corners
and whatnot and ultimately they um can kill the
most innocent and effectively wounds God's heart
the most um I spent a great deal time I did this
movie uh Deja Vu and I played it uh Unabomber and
I was on the phone with um um a friend a friend
of mine who broke the case and uh on Ted Bundy
and I talked to him a lot about uh serial killers
and then um I got to look at the um with the FBI
and the ATF gave me uh through Jerry Bruckheimer
and Tony Scott I got all these videos to look at
and the the um we I was looking at unabomers
uh guys that um blow things up and um an actual
serial killers but it was written more like a Ted
Bundy um and not a a man who is writing Destiny
and all of these things that he'd exchanged his
life to take out um whoever they want to take
out and but the the but the voice was very
similar and so I don't go to Satan to play
in this particular um Story I played this this
guy this um bomber and I don't go to the devil
to play the devil I think make many actors
make that mistake go to God to tell you who
the devil is that's what I do and it also gives
me a protection what's the difference what's the
difference Jim like because that also Bears
on how you protect yourself from such things
um the difference and are you saying um the
difference in the the difference is is that I
play the truth so if you go and play go to the
devil to play the devil the devil will deceive
you and put something up there that uh deceives
the public he'll always try to hide in the shadow
he'll always try because he doesn't like the light
even though he's called the light the Illuminator
um the Lucifer um and he tries to mimic God
he tries to be like God so there's always like
um if God has love and what we see is
love he creates lust he's always trying
to be like that it's like uh Kane trying
to rip off Abel cutting the corners and
um so committing to well there's a tendency even
in Milton's uh in in in Milton's Paradise Lost
there's been two readings of that forever and
one of them is that Milton's Satan is um an
anti-hero of the most profound sort really the
embodiment of evil and the other reading is that
um Milton Satan is a a disguised hero and
the Eternal what would you say the Eternal
rebel against established order and someone to
emulate in consequence and that Milton somehow
knew that and was coding that not precisely
secretly but subtly and I think that's a huge
mistake I mean I've familiarized myself with
Paradise Lost and I think that Milton was an
extraordinarily subtle writer in that he got
everything as right as anyone ever has but the
reason I'm bringing that up is because so this is
okay this is a complicated thing to untangle but
one of the things you see in Hollywood portrayals
of villains you saw this in the Silence of the
Lambs you see it frequently in Mafia portrayals
is that the villain is inadvertently or even
sometimes purposefully glorified and it's
partly because he's a rule breaker and and
has the attraction that goes along with that
but I also wonder too if it's it has something
to do with what you were describing is that
the writers and the actors find themselves
when they're trying to portray evil pulled
towards falseness in that representation as part
of the proclivity of evil to hide itself and the
danger in that is twofold and one is the danger
of deceiving the public as to the true nature of
evil because there's nothing heroic about it quite
the contrary and the second danger I wonder
about you know there's all this speculation
about Heath Ledger and the consequences that
for him of having played the Joker in such a
dark Manner and you know I don't know what to make
of that although I do think there is some danger
in having to Journey down a path of emulating
evil in order to represent it now you said that
you turned to God so to speak to protect yourself
against false representations of evil but also in
some ways to Shield yourself and it sounds to me
reminiscent of what Tim's uh superiors mentioned
to him when they said to him that his faith
might protect him from this question what was
okay go ahead man this is the best
interview I've ever had in my life I
love your line of questioning and um
getting to what what is real my job
uh is to give what I know to be absolutely certain
and real I hooked into Tim has a childlike quality
to him and I stay with that innocence and that and
don't take that innocence's weakness or uh and uh
so when I read the scripture I I feel
truth good evil and I find the good
and let that just pierce the darkness and it has
to pierce and I know what that light is and I know
that deception that when I start hearing about
for example in your life when you there's two
masters here one is from the evil Wicked side
but he comes in through your ego and the other
one is the light side that tells you might what
you might not want to hear but you ought to hear
and it's not manipulative it's truth so I I go to
that side then I pray then I go through it like
The Passion of the Christ I looked at the Shroud
of Turin and there were two men Christian Tinsley
and Keith vanderlin who are experts in makeup and
the first both of these men were agnostic and they
looked at the Shroud that Mel Gibson presented
to them and one particular way the way it is
uh through the negative however they were able to
show it you can see the track lines of Jesus you
can see the the the actual um bamboo sticks that
they used to to initially hit him and then you
see the cat of nine tails the track lines they
look like the Grand Canyon in your skin and it
shocked them now these guys look at everything
from decapitations murders and everything
prior to this I did a movie a long time ago in New
York and I was with homicide and I got to see the
contortion of a face when someone gets murdered
and it's hard to watch but when you start going
into this which is children there is something
that I can't even fathom even with the protection
of almighty God because it took me two years
to get over this two years in the a friend of
mine Debbie came into the room and at around three
o'clock in the middle of the night she I was in a
chair and she heard me just weeping now I would go
into these black holes and I have no idea I don't
remember it but this was all of the screaming
that I had to hear I didn't want to hear it but
I had to hear it and then I was able to transform
that into the movie that you just saw when I took
asked Alejandro monteverdi to move to our DP to
take it and show him my eyeball so you would see
a 20-foot eye to see what Tim goes through to rip
his heart out now it's not like uh this is what I
want to experience any more than I want to get on
a cross and have uh my heart broken I went through
hypothermia I had to have open heart surgery I was
electrocuted struck by lightning I understand the
the the necessity of what I was going to have
to go through could help bring people back to
God to wake them up and quite frankly more people
now Jordan are more afraid of the devil than they
are of God because they want a happy Jesus and
the problem is is that eventually Jordan we all
are going to die eventually that that is going
to happen but people the the power of the devil
deceives to say no no you're going to be around
for a long long time and and they never wake up
and eventually there's a judgment and then you
have to decide or God decides not how you want
to see yourself anymore but how God sees you and
how God sees you is who you really are and so
that's how I I chose to to go at this particular
case I had no choice but to go in and I hear the
screams in my heart I hear the screams because of
the agents that I got to work with got to show me
things and they one particular time he says are
you sure you want to go further but I was weeping
so hard I said this is what Tim goes through this
is what I got I got to see it in order to go into
there there to to take people to a level of will
you do something will you do something at some
point it ends for all of us and so the pain in my
heart is much better than the pain in the future
and if I have to see that to save my children to
motivate me to save my niece to tell my sister no
walking home at 13 years old from school is not a
good choice not a good choice my sister says to me
no I want my sister my daughter excuse me to have
the same kind of experience I have and I said no
not until this changes you need to understand
so and my sister is a good great mother but she
wasn't aware because the media that's supposed
to do a good job to tell the truth well they're
going into that direction which is let's kind of
twist it and change it and not talk about it or
the three letter agencies that aren't telling the
truth go ahead Jordan how has this changed you how
is how is experiencing that material and having
to play it out changed you I I I'd give my life
and a heartbeat changed me I'm less concerned
about myself than I am about hurting I I will tell
you this right now I would absolutely die if this
If This Were to change the world and get rid of
trafficking and pornography and all of the eight
arms of this octopus that has to be destroyed the
only way you can destroy is take the head out if
that hit I'd give my life for it in a heartbeat
Tim let me ask you a question Jim referred to
this is an awkward question I don't know how to
progress with it exactly right but he said that he
tried to play you with a certain kind of innocence
and you know there's a gospel line and the line
is unless you become as a little child you will
in no way enter the kingdom of heaven and it's
a very very subtle line because it doesn't say
unless you stay as a child right it says unless
you become as a child and and that's a very
it's a very paradoxical injunction and
it means something like this it means
if you ReDiscover the innocence and
humility and capacity for play and wonder
and open ended trust that you had as a child but
you still have all the wisdom that you have as an
adult after having seen the world then you have
entered into you might say a new domain and a
more elevated form of being and Jim said that he
was struck when talking to you about uh it with
regard to this childlike innocence that he saw
on you which is very peculiar thing to observe
in someone who's had to expose himself to all the
terrible things that you've encountered and so
I don't I don't have a more fully developed
question than that I I guess I just like
your response to that set of observations I do
think I think I know what Jim's talking about um
when we're doing operations as you see depicted in
sound of Freedom it's some crazy stuff we're going
into crazy places we're talking to uh monsters
and demons and if I were to apply all the things
I I know the things that take me down the images
of children um I could be jaded and and less less
innocent um I think this might go back to the the
the the the the boss who asked me to start this
work back in 2002 by saying that we think you can
handle this because of your faith so when I I do
try to be a child like childlike when it comes
to my relationship with with God and there's a
scripture that I repeat in my head constantly as
I am going into these dark places and that's where
I become like a child through that recitation and
my relationship with God or even more particularly
with Jesus um because it's Jesus who says the line
and you've already quoted it Jordan uh better than
a millstone be placed around your neck and you
toss through the bottom of the seed and that you
should hurt one of these little ones um that's so
powerful to me because it's it's so it it allows
me to read to read reduce everything to just an
innocent I hope childlike relationship with With
My Savior with my god um because I know where he
stands on this and I might not know everything
and I don't know how this is going to resolve in
my head I don't know how I'm going to heal the
millions of of holes burned into my brain but I
do know that if I subject myself completely to to
an understanding and a testimony that that Jesus
believes something he gets mafioso this is cement
shoes kind of talk uh it's not it's not it's not
flipping tables outside the temple I mean he's
talking about violence he's speaking violence
but it's it's righteous and that's where he
stands on children being abused and that's where
I find so there's a there's another idea there's
another idea that lurks in the passion account
hey that that's really quite stunning and horrible
so the the passion story is an archetypal
tragedy and the reason for that is that
a tragedy is when something terrible happens
to someone but uh a more profound tragedy is
when the worst possible thing happens to the
least deserving person and so that's the passion
story in some ways in a nutshell right you have
a man who by Universal admission even on the part
of his enemies is at minimum a very good man who
undergoes the worst possible sequence of betrayal
and Punishment and so that's the story of the
tragedy of human life writ large but there's more
to it than that because there's a mythological
insistence along with that that Christ was not
only crucified but that he had to descend into
the depths of Hell itself and Harrow it and what
that means to me psychologically speaking let's
say is that you're called upon before rebirth
that's a good way of thinking about it to not only
bear the brunt of the tragedy of existence but
to face malevolence head on right to go into
the deepest and darkest possible places and
what what do you say it's it's and and well
redeeming them to the degree that that's possible
simultaneously redeem yourself and so the
notion there is that the brightest possible
light is only possible through the descent into
the darkest possible realm of of Blackness and
that actually goes beyond death into malevolence
itself now Jim said you know because you might
say well there's nothing that you should be
more afraid of than death but Jim said you
know he's appalled enough about the existence of
malevolence that he would be willing to give his
life to eradicate it and so that obviously
means that for Jim malevolence itself is a
more terrifying Specter than than mere death
or even mere suffering and then there is this
gospel notion that unless you're willing to take
the weight of Hell onto yourself essentially um
voluntarily that you can't go through that process
of descent and rebirth and that is associated in
the in the gospel accounts let's say with that
rebirth into the spirit of childhood and so
you you have done what you could to face
the ultimate reaches of Darkness itself
what has that done for you and then also you
made some very interesting comments about your
wife you know you said that in some ways you were
hoping she would tell you to you know be sensible
and come home but she didn't she told you to
go put yourself on the line and there's a huge
story there that's touched on in the movie but
but not delved into in any to any great regard
um how has your encounter with the darkness that
you've seen made you a better person and and what
has that done with your relationship with your
wife I think it's it's made me a better person
because the the weight that you speak of
that that is on your back is unbearable
unless you can give it to some other power in this
case in my case to Jesus himself and that's what
to subject myself completely and repeat his words
in my mind because I know where he stands on it
he'll take it from me and I felt that I have
felt that in ways I can't even articulate that
don't make any sense on a scientific level I the
burden is lifted and that's what gives me Clarity
and courage to do things I otherwise wouldn't
dream of doing uh in order to help children and
it's it's a concept that my wife understands in
fact I'll tell you this she it's like she morphed
into some kind of a therapist in that moment after
she told me that her her salvation might be on the
line she's much more advanced than I am in every
way and especially spiritually and she helped me
to see that uh very thing that give the burden
to to God and and then you can be but you have
to subject yourself like a child in order to do
that and recognize you can't on your own do it
but she she ran me through this exercise don't
know where she got it maybe it was a download
from heaven but she said do you see the two paths
you're going on either you're going to Colombia
and you do this operation and what does that look
like and and I said it looks horrifying it's scary
it's dark because there's cobwebs I I mean I was
literally imagining this there's there's spiders
there's evil things and she said what's the other
path and I said well the other path is is light
um it's you know I I can see at 50 I get to
retire and then I don't have to you know I I'm
I'm paid a federal government salary my whole
life and benefits and that seems secure to me
and I that seems comfortable then she says close
your eyes and and you're with your maker you've
passed through this life and you're talking to
your maker and he has two questions for you one
could you have saved the kids and two did you
do it that's your interview and she's and and
I got it shocked me I thought oh that's going to
be a bad interview uh if I don't have the right
answer if I don't make the right decision here
and then she says okay now go back to those two
paths what do you see and I'm telling you the the
cobwebs and creepy things we're now on the path of
staying in my federal government comfortable job
I thought what might I lose what blessings might
not come and then she said what do you see down
the path of Colombia and she said I see I said I
see warmth I see I can't see everything but that's
the path I want and I think that's what that means
is I will give it to God and do the right thing
and subject myself like a child I hope that made
sense well well you know look the reason that
people lie and the reason they remain silent
is because they think that things
will be easier for them and better
at least in the short term but the psychological
literature on this is pretty damn clear I think
I think clearer than any other element of The
Clinical Psychology literature which is that
you avoid things that stand in your way
that frighten you at your great peril
if you cower from them in silence or you turn away
seeking Security even or even sensible security
you violate the principle of your own strength
and if you violate the principle of your own
strength you become weak and if you're weak
there is no security like if you're weak and
you have a pension you're weak with a pension all
that'll mean is that you'll live longer in Terror
that's not helpful and the alternative and that
there's also a an ethos in the biblical stories
in particular and it's a very interesting ethos
it's very much worth knowing and one is that
if you say the truth and and nothing else you'll
have a immense Adventure as a consequence you
won't know what's going to happen to you and
you have to let go of your clinging to the
to the outcome you have to let go but the truth
will reveal the world the way it's intended to
be revealed and the consequence for you will
be that you'll have the adventure of your life
and the other part of that ethos is this and it
makes perfect sense to me I I can't see how it
can be any other way which is that whatever makes
itself manifest as a consequence of the truth is
the best possible reality that could be manifest
even if you can't see it and you know in my own
life I've been attacked many times by people who
were attempting to demolish my reputation and take
me out and that's put my family at risk and many
times we've gone through this a lot and what we
have observed is that if we stick to our guns
and we say what we believe to be the case and
I say we because it's a collaborative Enterprise
I'm always discussing things with my family that
there's a period of intense discomfort and the but
the the in the aftermath of that and that's often
several months or sometimes even several years
later things switch around and reverse in in a
manner that brings benefits that can't even be
fathomed so so and it is a matter of Faith right
so the faith is something like this look are
you going to make your way through life with
silence and falsehoods are you going to make your
life your way through life with truth and there's
going to be a price for the truth but your vision
showed you there was a price for the security too
right once once you allowed your imagination
to manifest itself you saw that the pathway of
security was actually the one that was covered
with spider webs demons and snakes and you know
I see that I saw that with faculty members at
the University over and over they would take
the so-called secure path forward and all they did
was violate the Integrity of their own Souls right
all that security is false and obviously your
wife for some reason it's quite the miraculous
part of that story I would say that your wife
was behind you like that especially because you
said you had six kids at the time you know so how
do you think she knew this you said her faith is
more developed than yours and and that she knows
things you don't but what was it about her life
did you think that enabled her to stand behind you
and this crazy Venture you went on when she had
every reason to make you mean you were the movie
says you were within what months of vesting your
pension how many 12 weeks something like that I I
don't I don't I can't remember the exact time but
yeah that was the my accountant came to me and
showed me how much how many millions of dollars
this would amount to that I was walking away from
it was ridiculous I want to say 12 million dollars
or something a number I couldn't even fathom but
you're walking away from that and that really
tossed me and that's the thing that led me to
mccatherine and said this is what we'd be walking
away from why does she have this thing um I it's
a mystery to me I I can say this having having
given birth and raised six children I've watched
that process it's there's something I think that
happens to to women at least in the case of
my wife uh that um there's some insight that
comes from that process and and and childbirth
and rearing a child that she's had to rely on
God just to get through that process and then
have this little creature that you're in charge
of I I think her relationship with God allowed
through motherhood allowed her to have insights
um that I didn't have I think she came with
certain gifts as well that before this life
uh but whatever it was she saw immediately and
and on the spot was able to run me through that
exercise that really is consistent with with your
understanding of that process uh Dr Peterson so
um I don't know she's a miracle she's a
miracle to me and none of this would have
happened without her well okay so you you quit
your job and you put your pension on the line and
your wife was not only fully on board with that
but perversely enough encouraged you to do so
how has it how has the financial support that
made your continued existence and also the
operations that you've undertaken how has that
manifested itself since like you you don't have
your pension and the government behind you but
obviously you've gathered resources around you
personally and and practically
how tell me how that came about
well I'll add this piece because I that was my big
concern and Catherine said to me and she believed
it this is all in that same conversation she
said I don't care if we end up living in a tent
we will not go back to our maker instead we
didn't try to help these children so that's
so that helped ease my mind because I thought
well then okay if we lose our house uh now
the the the blessings did come uh you know
uh Glenn Beck was the person who actually
funded the rescue operation that you see
depicted in the film that very first one
um he got our he got us started put a huge amount
of faith and frankly risk in in in in doing that
um but that was going to get us only about six
to eight months before we would be in trouble
but what happened was the success happened the
peace that I felt in making the decision to go
was that New Path that I couldn't see everything
but it felt right it felt good it felt Godly and
I knew it'd be okay and we've never had a worse
month in the month before we've only grown with
success spread success donations start coming
in Opportunities come in and frankly I think
I'll be better off financially uh as I look
at my future than I would have been otherwise
right now you we we should just dwell on that
for a minute so we just we just won't dwell on
how unlikely that is say so let's let's just go
through this so you make this crazy decision to
quit your job and to forgo your your pension even
though you've basically vested it and you're well
into your career you're to the point where in
principle you could have contemplated retiring
and sitting to drink my Ties on the beach in
the Caribbean which I wouldn't recommend by
the way as a as a retirement plan and instead you
decide that and with your wife that you guys are
willing to you know risk living in a tent with
your kids but you're going to do this come hell
or high water and the consequence of that is that
perversely enough you're actually more financially
secure and you have more opportunities
than you would have otherwise had by a lot
right so that's worth thinking about right
that's really we're thinking about because
you threw yourself all in which is what you're
supposed to do and not only did that work on the
fight side because you have been able to rescue
these children and to continue this endeavor but
none of the things that you thought you
would lose you actually ended up losing
that's correct and I and I I'm thinking of
the words you just said five minutes ago about
when you take on the challenges you you lose that
weakness that you otherwise would have I'd rather
I'd you know I I don't want to be weak with with a
pension like you said I I was able to be stronger
and that strength is the thing that frankly
allowed me to expand my uh possibility of making
more income and and doing more things in fact
I often Journal um Jordan often when I have the
biggest challenges of my life that come and hit
in the face with this or that I I take note what
blessings came what good things came and sometimes
it's ninety percent of the good things before me
sprung out of that horrific challenge that the
darts thrown at me whatever it was and so the
principle that you're teaching really has played
out uh accurately in my life over and over again
yeah yeah yeah well I I think that's well it makes
sense in some sense look I mean if we want to just
think about it practically I mean you're going to
become stronger more confident more credible and a
better Communicator in precise proportion to the
burdens that you decide voluntarily to confront
and master like obviously because how could it
be any other way and then what that's going to
mean is that when you go communicate with people
and you tell them what you're doing they're much
more likely to jump on board because you have the
Charisma that goes along with having the stories
to tell and those encounters to to relate and the
success you've generated and and so then people
are going to offer to help you're not even going
to have to ask them and so let me let me ask you
about that you talked about Glenn Beck who else
has been instrumental in helping your operation
grow and providing you with support you mentioned
Tony Robbins as well and I've got to know Tony a
bit over the last last year or so I mean he's an
absolutely remarkable person and I think he might
be the most charismatic person I've ever met which
is really saying something because I've met some
very charismatic people and he's quite the monster
in the world and he's done an awful lot of good
and and he's obviously supporting he's supporting
you as well and is on board with this project and
so how did that come about well Tony Robbins is
in fact uh the the single largest donor to to
our operation I'm super super close with him his
his wife as well Sage Beautiful People beautiful
souls uh it came about in the most amazing way
uh during one of his big Mastermind conferences
and a a Convention Center of some sort there was
a woman who raised her hand when Tony asks about
bucket list uh projects if you had an excess of
whatever what would you do with it she raised
her hand and said I'd support a group called
operation Underground Railroad Tony says what
is that three minutes later he says I'll donate
I'll match whatever someone gives me right now to
help rescue children and and and that's where
the relationship was born he called me a few
days later and said is this real I said I felt it
was I said why don't you come down to Haiti with
me we're about to do an operation and you can
see how very real it is and he did and he saw
and that converted him to our cause so what's on
your plate next what what where is this going as
far as you're concerned and what sort of impact
what sort of impact have you had in sheer numbers
um why do you think you're not going to get
taken out because it seems to me that you're in a
situation where that's you know of reasonable high
probability given who you're dealing with and what
do you hope to accomplish over the next what do
you hope to accomplish over the next while and and
what can people do to help well so I've changed
quite a bit of how I look at the playing field of
human trafficking I can no longer do operations
I've been in the media too much especially with
this film I've turned a lot of my attention to
uh the fact that in what I call spiritual warfare
children are targeted like never before I was
uh I was on the Capitol Hill last week and this
congressman is telling me how do we wake people
up to the fact that all these unaccompanied minors
are being shoved into America and we don't know
where they are and and I said well your problem
is you're not connecting all the dots all the ways
in which children are being hurt not only these 85
000 missing children that are now on the belly of
of the largest potentially child sex Market in the
world um but at the same time that's happening
you have groups trying to get rid of the name
pedophile and call them minor attracted persons at
the same time you're you're sexualizing children
giving them what I used to be able to arrest you
for giving children now teachers in California
and other states are giving this in the name of
of liberal liberating children's sexually or sex
education and now a 13 year old can consent to
gender mutilation and inject them have themselves
injected with all sorts of chemicals that might
ruin their reproductive system well what are you
doing consent to do that equals consent eventually
to to sex with a 50 year old pedophile and so if
you you got to connect all these things and so I
I for the first time in my life Jordan I'm looking
at the United States of America and I'm saying
I'm saying look I used to think I might be out
of a job because we eradicated human trafficking
I am now thinking I might be out of a job because
the very laws that protect children and allow us
to go after their captors are being and will be
decaying and eroded with this crazy culture that
is taking children in the name of liberating them
and in fact is enslaving them so you know I
I interviewed this girl Chloe Cole who had
a double mastectomy when she was 15 and who had
puberty blockers and went through the whole bloody
gamut of incompetent lying therapists and sadistic
butchering surgeons and they transformed her
sexually and then she talked to me about her
dating experiences in high school now you can
just imagine this you know it's complicated
enough for a young man or a young woman in
high school to navigate the sexual Shoals let's
say and establish a reasonable relationship or
even a reasonable sequence of relationships
if everything is roughly normal or something
approximating ideal but Chloe put herself way
out on the fringes having done what she did
and that made that took her out of the dating
pool in high school for her compatriots and so
she turned to online dating and you can imagine
the sort of people who attempted to pick her up
and she didn't refer to that an awful lot in our
interview but she referred to it enough so that
I got a real flavor of the sort of people who uh
were more than perversely willing to strike up a
relationship with her often much older as you
pointed out and so you know that that freedom
that she was hypothetically offered that only
required the sacrifice of her breasts let's say
uh the wounds of which by the way have never
completely healed so that's perfectly goddamn
delightful and you know she talked about
her dissent into that perverse underworld
of of deviant sexual attraction and so uh yeah
there's not a lot of freedom on that front Jim
um what are you up to next like you finished
this movie it's going to open up on July 4th
um what what's what's next for you on the project
front and and also on the personal front in terms
of of your commitment to continuing the
work that you're starting with this movie
well it goes to the next chapter um which
is on Haiti and that's the next part of Tim
um when they went down and did this Haiti
Mission and this is a much better script
than the first one written by the same director
uh and Rod Barr Alejandro monteverdi wrote this
so I plan to do that film and um and then of
course I'm doing the resurrection of the Christ
with Mel Gibson so I think that's going to be
I think for sure it's one film but it might be
two films I think and when when so and what
do you see what do you foresee happening on
the uh on the theatrical release front I mean
I have the have the typical companies that are
involved in theatrical release in movies being
on board with the release of sound of Freedom
or have have you run into like enthusiastic
reception or resistance what's happened on that
front well we had a lot of resistance it took
us four years to get where we're at right now
um you know like The Passion of the Christ nobody
saw that as a of a financially feasible film same
thing with this who's going to want to watch
a film about traffic children that's why it
wasn't about that it was it it points in that
direction but it's really in the face of evil
can good still Triumph and that's what this film
is so it's quite inspirational you know well it
is a classic in many ways it is a classic action
adventure film I mean it's based on a true story
but it's got a very solid narrative driving line
I mean it's not fundamentally making its Appeal
on the moral side I mean there is an appeal on
the moral side don't get me wrong but that's
not good enough for a movie like a movie has to
carry its own weight as an artistic Endeavor and
it has to be well plotted and well well acted
and or just degenerates into kind of moralistic
propaganda I don't think this movie does that
at all I also didn't think that the chosen did
that angel Studios other major production it never
degenerated into sentimental moralizing thank God
and give that but something like that'll just flop
at the box office anyways and I certainly couldn't
see any reason after having watched this movie not
to think that this could be a commercial success
I mean it's a very exciting movie we're selling
out right now where our biggest War right now
is to get more theaters the big studios control
those and the Distributors have to decide whether
or not and this happened on The Passion of the
Christ whether to go and go where the people are
um and so the people are calling in right now
to you know ask for these theaters they're not
just going to angel.com I've known many people
that have gone in and literally bought out all
theaters uh to do this and so we're hoping that
this continues because we won't be able to serve
the public we just don't have enough theaters
right now well that's that's a good problem to
have I would say and that should get also get you
the kind of publicity that should also further
distribution of the film and of course there's
alternative routes now too I mean Matt Walsh had
tremendous success Distributing what is a woman
on Twitter I think they got 170 million views
and you know I don't know how successful that
was commercially and of course that's a problem
because Financial issues matter but there's
definitely multiple venues now where a film
like this can be can be distributed and of course
Angel Studios had a hell of a success Distributing
what they produced on the on the chosen
front using rather unorthodox channels online
and we're fortunate enough uh Jordan to get
Elon Musk he he actually tweeted out a couple
weeks ago with the trailer and opened up Twitter
as a free home for distribution um uh and that
and they're gonna you're gonna we're gonna see a
Twitter release uh I think mid-july so that that
will be fun to see what happens there oh so that's
already in play all right well all right well look
gentlemen we're running out of time on the YouTube
front um as everybody watching and listening or at
least to some people watching and listening no I
do add another half an hour of interview on The
Daily wire plus side and so I think we'll turn
our attention to that I'm gonna find out from
from Tim and Jim what developmental route they
took to the destination that they arrived at
um I haven't done that with two people before but
I think that will be quite entertaining and so
um I'm interested in how people's Destinies make
themselves manifest across time or you might say
how they're calling uh makes itself uh makes its
appearance in their life because things do call to
people you know everybody has problems that beset
them that are their problems and everybody has
opportunities that back into them that are their
opportunities and that's kind of a mysterious
what would you say Bargain and interplay
between the psyche and the world and uh I'm
endlessly curious about how that happens and
so we're going to follow down that road as we
continue this conversation
on the daily word plus side
um by the way for those of you who are watching
and listening if you're thinking about uh throwing
some support the daily wire plus way is probably
a good time to think about doing that because uh
they and I for that matter have been under a
fair bit of pressure from YouTube in the last
month I've had three of my interviews taken
down and I suspect there's a couple on the in
the pipelines that are also going to raise the
hackles of the wrong people whoever the hell
they are lurking behind the scenes and so uh
yeah yeah well you never know right you can't
tell what rules you broke and you can't tell
who's enforcing the censorship rules um which
is real really not good on any front so anyways
we're going to turn our attention over there
um thank you to Jim Caviezel and Tim Bellard
for talking today uh I really enjoyed your film
I'm I'm looking forward to watching how the public
will receive it and and what the consequences will
be and wish you both luck in your future endeavors
and uh and yeah and Tim Mouse I will hook up hook
you up your wife up with my wife and it'd be real
interesting to have them talk about you know how
she saw what you were doing and and why she threw
her weight behind it because there's quite a story
there as well as far as I can tell I'm very
much looking forward to watching that interview
all right gentlemen it was good to talk
to both of you and uh thank you everyone
watching and listening thanks for your
time and attention pay some attention
to this movie if you're inclined you
bet guys you bet good to meet you both
[Music]